pen little eastern identity is I'm
thinking of it only was something that
emerged I think after nine eleven part
that the part of it was that suddenly
Syrians Lebanese Palestinians Iranians
Iraqis that we all got clumped together
you know there was more misunderstanding
than ever even though people were now I
would think able to locate countries of
the Middle East more than ever on the
map but there was a slight guetta with
cessation if you can say of all Middle
Eastern people so I became very
interested in them and my novel deals a
lot with Pam Middle Eastern identity but
specifically related to Middle Eastern
men and I and I know there'd been a lot
of literature and a lot of human
interest articles on Middle Eastern
women but not a lot of talk that Middle
Eastern men and you know that seems
strange to me not you know 911 had a lot
to do with the psyche of Middle Eastern
men versus the psyche of Western then so
it became something that was endlessly
fascinating to me and it continues to be
as I work on a second book
I think Iran ians and Arabs contrary to
some popular belief you know have never
been very friendly right so it always
felt that one specially talking about
the sort of Panama least an identity it
always feels a little bit strange to
talk for Arabs of the region to but I've
become very interested in all those
countries and and I have felt that we've
all been sort of clumped together
resentment personally I've never
experienced resentment personally
because also I I tend to pass for many
different things just visually you know
that's always been a strange feeling in
New York I passes Greek Italian you know
Jewish in California they know Matt
Mexican you know whatever I've always
been able to and my name is so foreign
like I said even to Iranians that I was
never put into a particular niche so I
I'd never had the experience of going
through any sort of hostilities from any
anybody my father and my brother have
they look more like your typical Iranian
men you know I say that with reservation
of course but they had experienced some
of that and I was very that's why I was
much more interested in their story I'm
also very interested within how gender
and race factors into this there's quite
a different perception of Middle Eastern
women for instance as victims as the
oppressed which I think most Middle
Eastern women can't stand although
especially in the world of publishing
it's interesting how much that image has
been perpetuated and how much money has
even come out of that image